préparons-nous pour aller au lit Je n'aime pas
ça quand vous les garçons regardez des trucs comme
ça avant de vous coucher ok pas ta mère garde
ce n'est pas vrai ouais mais ça va quand même te donner des
cauchemars il y a des références à
boggle dans toutes les cultures certains croyaient
que  il a vécu dans un autre royaume et d'
autres pensent que cela a nourri Oh pour la
corruption de l'innocence accessible uniquement
par rituel ou sacrifice il y a toujours
trois choses en commun il y a une
famille assassinée la maison sous une forme
d'offre d'image littérature musique
il y a un problème j'ai trouvé une autre maison
eh bien brûlez-le ce n'est pas si
simple il y a déjà une famille qui
vit là-dedans tuez n'importe qui vous tuerez
vous et toute votre famille et regardez le
film